So again,
this is what we're interested in.
A scene, and
of course we have two projection planes.
And we know from our work
that we did in modeling or
being able to kind of look at warps,
that we basically need to find a new p,
prime, that basically is kind of a warp
our projection from the original p.
And these are the two images we have.
Of course if you recall, we knew how
to do this with an equation like this.
And of course, this was
the homogenous coordinate system, and
these are trying to
get to the new pixels.
This is basically used in order to
introduce a concept of homography
between two images.
So the idea really is,
how can we relate two images,
which have the same camera center?
Again remember, the camera was
rotating and getting newer points.
And again this rotation might
actually create a different plane.
I refer you back to some of the earlier
visuals I showed you on that one.
So the basic idea and
this is, this is a rectangle.
And again remembering the properties
of these types of equations.
A rectangle should make, should map
to any arbitrary quadrilateral.
Again lines should remain lines.
They do not have to be parallel.
So the shape of this para,
this region might change, but
overall it will remain a quadrilateral.
It'll have straight lines.
So again,
parallel lines won't be parallel,
but lines will remain straight.
As we know again, this is something
we have looked at before when we
looked at this whole equation.
Now, of course you may remember,
that i in this one is always equal to 1,
and we have eight parameters
that we need to now model.